this morning the National Weather
Service warns of a dangerous and
life-threatening situation along the
Arkansas River Manuel Bojorquez is along
the river in Barling Arkansas near the
Oklahoma border man well good morning
good morning the river is expected to
rise another three feet over the next
several days and already you can see
just how Swift the current is over what
was a road here now the type of flooding
you're seeing here is also devastating
neighborhoods in this area drone video
shows homes and businesses surrounded by
water in Fort Smith the river is
expected to crest Wednesday around 20
feet above flood stage breaking a record
set in 1945 potentially catastrophic
flooding is expected in some areas near
Barling yesterday two Army Corps
Engineers assessing a dam had to be
rescued by helicopter after they were
trapped by the rising waters which are
also putting stress on dams and levees
Barling police officer James Breeden
told us he's never seen the water this
high there's a great deal of concern
about the levees holding out here is a
concern about the integrity of the
levels they've never been tested to this
limit before what are we talking about
the potential impact of one of those
levees not holding the potential impact
is literally tens of thousands of people
would be without a place to live it
would wipe out that many homes even
after the river crests Breeden says it
may not start to go back down until
possibly friday and then it could be
weeks before it returns to its normal
level Gayle oh boy thank you very much
Manuel Bojorquez